[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها في
ابرز العناوين
بيلاروسيا تعلن عن مناورات عسكريه مكثفه
مع موسكو على حرب المدن
[تصفيق]
السجن لابنه الرئيس الايرانيه الاسبق
هاشمي رفسا جاني خمس سنوات
والاضرابات تتسع في يوم الانتقام تحديدا
بسياسه الاعدام
تظاهرات في مدن اوروبيه لاحياء ذكرى
الثالثه لحادث الطائره الاوكرانيه ودعوات
لمحاسبه الحرس الثوري الايراني
المالكه في مقابلات جديده وصحف بريطانيه
تقول انه باع عائلته من اجل المال
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
البدايه من الحلقه اوكرانيا حيث قتلت
وزاره الدفاع في بيلاروسيا
تدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بناء على ما
اكتسبت روسيا من خبره في القتال في
اوكرانيا مع التركيز على ما وصفوه بحرب
المدن
وقالت وزاره الدفاع انها عزت عونها مع
نظيرتها الروسيه حيث تخططان لاجراء
تدريبات جويه مشتركه
واشارت الى ان التدريبات على حرب المدن
تحضى باهتمام خاص في هذه المناورات
وياتي التعاون العسكريه المكثف بين
البلدين الحديثين وستتقهنات في اوكرانيا
والغرب بان موسكو قد تستغل مسك كماصه
انطلاق لشنه هجوم جديد على اوكرانيا من
جهه الشمال
هذا وافاد تقرير بريطاني بان القوات
الروسيه تعزز دفاعاتها في منطقتي ذا
فروجيا ولوجانس باوكرانيا تحسبا لهجوم
كبير للقوات الاوكرانيه
التقرير رجح ان يشكل تحقيق القوات
الاوكرانيه لتقدم كبير في زافروجي يتحديا
للجسر البري الروسي الذي يربط منطقه
الرستوف الروسيه مع شبه جزيره القرم اما
في مدينه باخمود فما تزالوا المعارك تحتدم
فيما تدور معارك ضاريه وسط سوليدار مقاطعه
دونيس حيث يتواصلوا القصف المتبادل لدفع
الجيش الاوكرانيه على الانسحاب
وقبل ذلك القوات الروسيه قصف مناطق بشرق
اوكرانيا عقب انتهاء الهدنه التي اعلنها
الرئيس
عن تعبئه روسيه جديده لاستخدام 5000 جندي
للقتال في اوكرانيا
في هذه الاثناء اظهرت الصور حجم الدمار في
احدى القرى الواقعه في منطقه دونيسك
باوكرانيا حيث امضى السكان الباقون اعياد
الميلاد في منازل مدمره جراء القصف
المتبادل في ظل ازمه امدادات في الكهرباء
والمياه
[موسيقى]
وفي خطبه وصفت بالانتقاميه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تنفيذ ضربه لمقتل جنودروس
في ضربه صاروخيه في ماكيفكا ليله راس
السنه وقالت الدفاع الروسيه انها قصفت
مبنى في اكرامترز شرقي اوكرانيا ما ادى
بحياتي اكثر من 600 جندي اوكرانيه حسب
البيان
واكد الجيش الروسي احباط وهجوم الاوكراني
مضاد في محوري دوناتس
معي ابن موسكو الاهلى المزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد ومنكياب
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل ومن
دونيسك مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر ابدا
رائد الاغبر ابدا معك عبد الجواد تقارير
عسكريه غربيه تتحدث عن حشد القوات الروسيه
لمزيد من الجنود على جبهتي ذا فروجيا
والوغانس تحسبا لهجوم كبير للقوات
الاوكرانيه ما مدى دقه هذه المعلومات او
على الاقل الروايه الروسيه لما يجري هنا
مساء الخير طالب لك والي الزملاء بالفعل
يعني في الحقيقه تلك المناطق الان تعيش
حاله من التصعيد العسكري وخساره متر واحد
كما يتحدث الجانب الروسي يعتبر خطا فادحا
في سير العمليات العسكريه لذلك كما ترى
الدائره العسكريه في البلاد والدائره
السياسيه بان بان انشاء خط دفاع في العديد
من المناطق خاصه في زبرجه وهي الاقرب الى
منطقه السياده الاوكرانيه هو امر مهمه
للغايه حفاظا على الجنود الروس حفاظا على
المعدات الروسيه وحفاظه على المواطنين
الذين تم اجلائهم من تلك المناطق النحو
مناطق اكثر امنا لكن طالب اليوم كما نلاحظ
وبعد نهايه هذه الادنى التصعيد العسكري من
كلا الجانبين لكن على ما يبدو ان موسكو
ذاهبه للانتقام بشكل واضح حدث عشيه راس
السنه للمره الاولى بيان وزاره الدفاع
يتحدث عن اسقاط اكثر من مقاتله وطائره
حربيه اوكرانيه بالاضافه الى مسيرات مخازن
للسلاح النقاط بحثيه عسكريه بالاضافه الى
هذا العدد الكبير من الجنود الذين تم
تحديدهم وعلى الارجح ان الاصابات بالعشرات
في تلك المناطق حسب الروايه الروسيه عبد
الجواد داني انقل هذا التساؤل الى حذيفه
حذيفه جديد اخبار المعارك وما بلد دقه
المعلومات بان القوات الاوكرانيه تتهيا
لشني هجوم واسع النطاق على جبتي
نعم مساء الخير يا طالب في الحقيقه يعني
الجيش الاوكراني بشكل واضح تحدث خلال
اليومين الماضيين عن خططه في الفتره
القادمه قال طبعا اولا ان الامدادات
العسكريه الغربيه التي ستصل في الاسابيع
القادمه الى داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وستصل الى جبهه القتال هي التي ستحدد ااه
المعارك في الفتره القادمه ولكن التوقعات
ان تصل ذروه الهجوم والمحاوله استرداد
واستعاده الاراضي الاوكرانيه في مارس
القادم هذا بحسب بدانا وهو رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه طبعا
الان همم المدرعات التي ينتظرها الجيش
الاوكراني وهي مدرعات تستطيع القيام
بمهامه هجوميه وكذلك دفاعيه والدبابات
الفرنسيه ايضا اي ام اكس 10 والتي ايضا ان
تصل الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه في الاسابيع
القليله همم
بالاضافه طبعا الى المدفعيه
الطلقات للمدفعيه 155 هي التي
ستعزز من خطط القوات الاوكرانيه الان
القوات الاوكرانيه تركز على الدفاع عن
مناطق بعينها نتحدث عن سوليدار وعن باكو
عن هذا المحور وتقوم بعمليات هجوميه في
منطقه لوغانس كوتحاول السيطره طبعا على
منطقه صفاطف مدينه صفاطف وهي تعتبر همم
منطقه استراتيجيه اذ انها سوف تكون في عمق
خط دفاع الاتحاد الروسي طيب حذيفه انتقل
الى رائد اخر ما وصلت من اخبار المعارك
والمواجهات خصوصا المعارك في صن دارك كما
ذكر منذ قليل حذيفه
يعني بدايه طالب لابد من الحديث الى ان
القصف المتبادل عاد الى الذروه كما كان
عليه قبل الهدنه والعمليات العسكريه باتت
عنيفه مثل ما كانت في السابق خاصه
الذين يقاتلون في سندار قوات فاجنر الخاصه
الروسيه بالفعل اعلنت قوات بانر او قياده
العسكريه لهذه المجموعه عن سيطرتها على
احدى البلدات اطراف مدينه سليدار من
الناحيه الشماليه منذ اكثر من شهرين وجيش
الروسي
مدينه باخمه من الناحيه الجنوبيه ومن
الناحيه الشرقيه وكان لا يكفي عليه اكمال
الطوق من الناحيه الشماليه طبعا المدينه
تقع شمال مقاطعه الان مع الضغط عسكريه
كبيره لهذا المحور الس بدات القوات
الروسيه بالتعاون مع مجموعات باجنر
والقوات الشيشانيه باكمال الطوق على شكل
هلال ودفع القوات همم الاوكرانيه من
انسحاب مع يعني تزامنا مع القصف العنيف
يعني المسيرات وكذلك السلاح الجو الروسي
هذا كله يعمل في
ان ال الاوكرانيات مجبره على الانسحاب
باتجاه الغربي وتسليم مدينه حتى الان ما
زالت القوات الاوكرانيه تقاوم في هذا
المحور لكن كما اسلفت عن الضربه
الانتقاميه الروسيه لابد من الاشاره الى
ان هذه الضربه قالت ايه يعني مصادر هنا
بان همم المقاتلات الروسيه قصفت لصواريخ
استراتيجيه موقعي مختلفين احد المواقع كان
يتركز به اكثر من 700 مقاتل والموقع
الثاني كان فيه همم اكثر من ثقه 600 مقاتل
النتيجه او الحصيله
الذين نحتهم القوات الروسيه 6 مقابل
الاصابات طيب ممن هم ما زالوا تحت الانقاذ
حتى الان طيب رائد انا ساعود اليك بعد
قليل لاسالك عن بخموت ولا انا اسالك يعني
في كلام ايضا عن احتمال شن هجوم روسي بيلا
روسي مشترك من جهه الشمال ساسالك بعد قليل
ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معي اعود الى عبد
الجواد عبد الجواد ايضا تقارير غربيه
تتوقع تعبئه روسيه جديده ل 500,000 جندي
والكلام لهم هل فعلا الامور ذاهبه بهذا
الاتجاه هل تمت مؤشرات على هذا الامر ام
لا هذا ضمن الحرب النفسيه الغربيه
طالب يعني في الحقيقه على ارض الواقع هو
جزء من الحرب النفسيه لا اخفيك القول بان
القلق يسود الشارع الروسي الكثير من
الشباب الروسي خرج خارج البلاد والعديد من
الاسر الروسيه استقبلت عامها الجديد خارج
حدود الوطن لكن حتى هذه اللحظه والاعلام
الرسمي جاء على لسان مجلس الدومه والفرقه
العسكريه هناك التي تحدثت بان التعبئه
الجديده لن تكون قبل نحوي سته اشهر اذا
احتاج الموقف هناك خاصه مع قيام رمضان
قديره في يوم امس بالاعلان عن ادخال فرقه
من قوات الامون التي تعرف بشكل جيد خططه
حرب الشوارع في تلك الاراضي العمليه
العسكريه وايصالها الى دانيه للمشاركه في
الضربات الروسيه على يعني على العام في
الاعمال العسكريه ايضا طالب على الجهه
الاخرى انه لاحظ بان التعاون العسكري وعلى
الارجح التعبير هو الاتحاد ده العسكري بين
موسكو وميز اوصل الكثير من الجنود الروسي
الى الاراضي البيلاروسيه هناك جنود طبعا
يملكون من الخبره كبيره يعملون هناك وهناك
من الجدد من تم تعبئهم تم اشراقهم ايضا في
تلك التدريبات هي ليست التدريبات الاولى
ولن تكون الاخيره على ما يبدو خلال هذه
الفتره هذه التدريبات بدات من العيار
الثقيل من شهر فبراير الماضي كانت على عده
مراحل في الشتاء والصيف وهدفها كما تعرف
طبعا تعزيز القوه العسكريه
على الحدود
الى حذيفه حذيفه اولا همم في تقارير تحدثت
عن عمليات انزال لقوات خاصه روسيه في
خاركه ما الذي يجري في خارج كيف وهل فعلا
يعني الامور تتجه الى فتح جبهه من الشمال
من بلا روسي يعني في تقارير تتزايد عن هذا
الاحتمال على الاقل الروايه الاوكرانيه
لجبهه الشمال
نعم في الحقيقه او وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه وتحديدا الهيئه الاركان
المشتركه تحدثت عن تزايد تراكم كما سمته
الجنود الروس والحسد في جبهه خاركيف لكنها
لم تتحدث عن تحركات جديده للقوات الروسيه
في تلك الجبهه طبعا تعلم ان هذه الفتره هي
فتره الحج للجانبين الجانبين يعمل على حسب
الموارد وكان الجنود اول اليات والمدرعات
والاسلحه ل- اا ليكونوا جاهزين للفتره ما
بعد فتره شهر مارس وهي التي كما توقعت
وقالت همم هيئه الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه انها سوف تكون الذروه المعارك
بين الجانبين في الحقيقه الجبهه خارقه
فيها الان هادئه ولكن عمليه جمع الموارد
مستمره من قبل الاتحاد الروسي ايضا في
جبهه اللوجاز هنالك محاوله لتقدم بطيئه
جدا من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه وكذلك حج
كبير للموارد وهذا السبب الذي دعى القوات
الاوكرانيه بضربه استراتيجي صفاته كريمنا
حتى تمنع يعني تجمع او همم الموارد وخاصه
من منطقه الروسيه اما جبهه بخمه تحديدا
فاذا تحدثنا عن المدينه نفسها فالقوات
الاوكرانيه تقول انها صامده على المسؤولين
ظاهر عدد من المسؤولين العسكريين جبهه
باخذه قالوا ان المدينه جبهه المدينه هي
صامده ولكن الوضع ماساوي في المدينه على
المواطنطينيه
هل فعلا تتهيا القوات الروسيه كما تشير
معلومات الى هجوم واسع لاستعاده كامل ام
لا هذا الكلام غير دقيق
بالطبع على القوات الروسيه تسعى يعني
لانهاء ازمه باقه حيث ان القوات الخاصه
اكثر من شهرين وهي تحاول تطويف المدينه في
هذه الايام تعتبر قوات بادنه قد اكملت
الطوق من الثلاث نواحي كما 3 بالفعل طالب
هناك قصف عنيف على المدينه وهناك يعني ضخ
بالقوات وامدادات عسكريه كبيره من القوات
الشيشانيه
الذين تم تجميدهم الرؤوس القوات الروسيه
التي تم تجميدهم بعد التعبئه الجزئيه على
الاغلب مدينه يمكن ان تسقط خلال ايام و
خلال شهر او شهرين على الاكثر ستسقط لان
جانب الاوكراني نفسه يؤكد بان همم
القوات الروسيه هي التي تقصف وهي التي
تتقدم وتسيطر على بلده في كل ضواحي من
النواحي الشماليه والشرق الجنوبيه لكن
الاهم من ذلك
يعني طالب بان القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا
تقصف هنا قالت الدفاع الروسيه بان اكثر من
500 قذيفه وصاروخ ابان بدنا سقطت على
المقاطعه بالامس كان هناك قصف انابيب
امداد الغاز في لوغانسكي قطعه امدادات
الغاز عن اكثر من 13,000 مشترك ايضا همم
قصفت هنا محطات للطاقه فدانيتك اليوم وكان
هناك قتيلتين ومن من ما زالوا تحت الانفاق
حتى الان القوات الروسيه ايضا لديها
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من المعلومات شكرا
جزيلا لك رائد الاكبر من دونسك من موسكو
كان معي مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
وشكرا ايضا لمراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل كان
معي همم
ايضا هو في ما يتعلق بالاسلحه الغربيه
لاوكرانيا قال وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه
انطونيو تيامي ان بلاده تبحث مع فرنسا
مساله تصدير انظمه دفاع جوي ذاتي انتاج
المشترك لاوكرانيا واضافه الوزير ان هذا
ياتي مع حزمه من المساعدات العسكريه
لمواجهه الهجمات الروسيه
الايطاليه
قبل صدور قرار من البرلمان
الحرب في اوكرانيا بين الحيله والخداع
حيله اوكرانيه تكلف روسيا ملايين
الدولارات في ساحه المعركه
فرق من الجنود الاوكرانيين تصنع قنبله
يدويه ذات وزن خفيف تستطيع تدمير دبابه
الروسيه تزن نحو 40 طنا
نيويورك تايمز
التكنولوجيه في ساحه المعركه على
الاستخدام المتزايد للطائرات الصغيره من
دون طياره
الطائرات الصغيره من دون طيار تقوم بمهامه
الاستطلاع وتعمل على تصحيح نيران المدفعيه
يحاول الجنود الاوكرانيون رفع فعاليه
الطائرات بدون طيار من خلال استخدامها
لربن القنبله المثاليه
اوكرانيا تستخدم مافيك ثلاثه صينيه الصنع
صغيره الحجم وعمر بطاريتها مناسب تستخدم
ضد تجمعات القوه والخنادق
[موسيقى]
روسيا تستخدم الاكبر حجما طائره شاهد
ايرانيه الصنع تطلق بشكل متكرر لتدمير
البنيه التحتيه في اوكرانيا
الاشراف على المحتوى وخطاب الكلام
اهلا بكم جديد الى ايران حيث افادت تقارير
ايرانيه بصدور حكم بالسجن بحق الفائزه
نفساني ابنه الرئيس الاسبق هاشمي رفس
الجاني خمس سنوات
الدعايه ضد النظام ونشر الفوضى يذكر ان
الفائزه هاشمي عضو في حزب كوادر البناء
الاصلاحي
وفي هذه الاثناء واستجابتين لدعوات تظاهر
اليوم تحت عنوان يوم الانتقام تظهر
ايرانيون احتجاجا على ممارسات النظام التي
وصفوها بالقمر فيما اظهرت الصور اغلاق
اصحاب المحال لما تجريهم تضامنا مع
المحتاجين وتمديدا بسياسه الاعدام
[تصفيق]
اذا استدعى وزير الخارجيه الهولنديه
السفيره الايراني في اعقاب اعدام متظاهرين
اثنين وداع الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى فعل الشيء نفسه وقال الوزير
الهولندي عبر رساله على تويتر ان عمليات
الاعدام المروعه التي نفذتها الحكومه
الايرانيه مفزعه مضيفا انه هولندا
تعد بالفعل حزمه الرابعه من العقوبات ضد
ايران وتحتزم وتقديمها في اجتماع مجلس
الشؤون الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
المقبله
[موسيقى]
في غضون ذلك اعلم القضاء الايراني اصدار
احكام بالسجن لفترات متفاوته ضد اربعه
اشخاص بسبب دعوتهم الى الاضراب دعم
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه التي تشهدها البلاد
منذ مقتل الفتاه
وقال مسؤول بالسلطه القضائيه اصدر الاحكام
الابتدائيه
ياسمين
[موسيقى]
لسياسه الاعدامات التي يتبعها النظام نقلت
صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن المدير التنفيذي
لمركز حقوق الانسان في ايران هذه غيري
قوله ان تنفيذ عمليات الاعدام التي جرت
بحق اربعه متظاهرين حتى الان لم تتم من
خلال اجراءات قضائيه بل انهم قتلوا خارج
نطاق القانون مشيرا الى ان المعتقلين
يتعرضون في كثير من الاحيان للتعذيب
الجسدي والنفسي ويجبرون على الاعتراف تحت
التهديد
المدير التنفيذي لمركز حقوق الانسان في
ايران اكد ان النظام يستخدمه عمليات
الاعدام والقوه المميته ضد المتظاهرين في
الشوارع لبث الرعب في قلوب المواطنين
وصرحت عضوه لجنه متابعه اوضاع المحتجزين
شيفا نزار هاري انا اكثر من 80 شخصا
يواجهون حاليا تهاما قد تؤدي الى عقوبه
الاعدام مشيرتان الى ان ثمانيه اشخاص
اخرين ما زالوا ينتظرون تنفيذا حكم
الاعدام بحقهم
الثالوث امام
ورغم القبضه الامنيه التي تفرضها السلطات
في ايران الا ان التقارير اشارت الى
انقسام داخل النظام نفسه حول طريقه الرد
على الاحتجاجات ونظام الايراني منقسم
داخليا بين صقور وحمائم في مدى القمع
اثناء الاسماء ويقول مراقبون ان الموافقه
على اعاده محاكمه عدد من المحتاجين حكم
عليهم بالاعدام والافراج عن معارضين
بارزين اخرين يحمل مؤشرات على ان البعض
يسعى الى نهج اكثر ليوناتا الا ان تنفيذ
حكم الاعدام بحق رجلين مؤخرا لقتلهما عنصر
من قوات البسيج خلال اضطرابات مرتبطه
بالاحتجاجات اتى ليذكر بالمسار المتشدد
المراقبون فسروا ايضا سياسه توقيف
المشاهير والافراج عنهم بعد وقت قصير كما
حدث مع الممثل الشهيره ترانا عليدو سيتي
بانها بمثابه تخويف لكن ايضا لجس النبض
لمعرفه ما سيكون عليه رد الفعل ويقول اكشن
شاي وهو الاستاذ المشارك في دراسات الشرق
الاوسط في جامعه كيف انجلترا ان التساهل
الذي تظهره السلطات احيانا هو محاوله لمنع
حصول مزيد من الانقسامات داخل المؤسسات
الامنيه اذ ان القمع ادى الى نفور بعض
اعضائها فهي اضاف ان النظام لا يبدو ان
لديه استراتيجيه واضحه ردا على الغضب
الشعبي
خرجت مظاهرات في مدن الاوروبيه عد احياء
لذكرى الثالثه لحادث سقوط الطائره
الاوكرانيه التي اسقطها الحرس الثوري في
وقت في وقت طالبت فيه الحكومه الكنديه
ايران
بتحكيم ملزم يرتكز على التخفاقيه مونتريال
التي تنظم تسويه الجرائم ضد الطيران
الثالث على التوالي يرفع اهالي ضحايا
الطائره الاوكرانيه التي اسقطها الحرس
الثوري الايراني صور احبائهم التي لم تبقى
سوىها
الكارثيه انا وعائله الضحايا نطلب معرفه
لماذا ارتكبت هذه الكارثه ومن كان وراءها
انه من حقنا والقتله يجب محاكمتهم
ومعاقبتهم في المحاكم الدوليه وهذا مطلبنا
من العالم ومن النظام الايراني
جمه
وري الحكومه الكنديه
لاسقاط الطائره طلب الطهران باجراء تحكيم
وتورتكزات في طلب التحكيم على اتفاقيه
مونتريال التي تنظم تسويه الجرائم ضد
الطيران على انه اذا لم يتفق الطرفان خلال
سته اشهر ترفع القضيه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
167 مسافرا بريئا على متن الطائره القادمه
من ايران الى اوكرانيا
كانت عمده وبالتالي عليكم ان تعلن
وتعترفوا بان كل الحرس الثوري الايراني
منظمه ارهابيه واذا لم تتعاون معكم ايران
في القضيه يجب ان تتحول الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
هل الضحيه تجمعوا امام مبنى منظمه الطيران
المدني الدولي في مونتريال مطالبين بعدم
الوثوق بايران وتحويل القضيه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
اختلفت مراسم ذكرى سقوط الطائره هذا العام
لانها تزامنت مع احتجاجات تشهدها مدن
ايرانيه عده ارتفعت فيها اصوات المحتاجين
لاسر الضحايا ومطالبين بمحاسبه متورطين
وعلى راسهم خامن رفعها السعد العربي
[موسيقى]
معي هنا في الاستديو لمزيد من المتابعه
لهذا الموضوع مراسله العربيه في كندا رفها
سعد رفا اهلا وسهلا بك منافسه جهات
العربيه في دبي هل فعلا الحكومه الكنديه
جابه في الذهاب في هذه القضيه الى النهايه
ام لا هي كالاروبيين ينتقدون ينجدون في
العلم ولكن على المستوى العملي لا شيء
فعلا
ضحايا بهذا الموضوع تباينه الاراء الاسر
بعضهم ذكر ان الحكومه الان فعلا الحكومه
الكنديه جاده بعد ان وجدت ان النظام
الايراني يراوغ للنداء ثلاث سنوات لم تحصل
على تعويضات لم تظهر الحقيقه لم تكشف
الاوراق لماذا ترك النظام الايراني لمجال
الجوي مفتوح انا ذاك ولماذا قصف الحرس
الثوري الايراني حسب ما يذكر هذه الضحايا
ان القصف كان عمدا لكن بعض الاسر مثل همم
خليني احكي بالاسماء لان مثل شاهين الذي
فقد ابنه وزوجته وابنته
قال لا انا لا اعتبرها انها خطوه جيده لان
على الحكومه الكنديه وهي تعلم ان النظام
الايراني غير جاد كان يجب عليها ان تاخذ
القضيه مباشره للمحاكم الجنائيه الدوليه
لان النظام الايراني سيراوغ وسيستمر لمده
حتى لو نقول لمده 10 سنوات لم يكتفي
النظام الايراني بالمراوغه فكانت الاراء
متباينه لكن على اذا نحكي سياسيه فالحكومه
الكنديه وخاصه وزيره الخارجيه يوم امس
التقت اسر الضحايا وقالت لهم انتم فعلا
تستحقون العداله ووسن وسنسعى لجلبها لكم
وسنقض القضيه الى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
في اخذ هذه القضيه الى الجنائيه الدوليه
يعني مضى نحو ثلاث سنوات ما الذي تخشاه ان
صح التعبير وهذا السؤال ايضا تساله
عندما نلتقي المسؤولين يقولون ان هذه
الاجراءات قانونيه وهذه اجراءات سياسيه
نعلم صرت الضحايا لهم قلوب محروق على
احبائهم لكننا لا يجب ان نكون متسرعين
ويجب ان ناخذ الخطوات الجديه قانونيه هم
يعتبرون نفسهم انهم يسيرون في المجال
القانوني انه خطوه بخطوه صحيح تاخذ وقت
حسب ما يذكرون طبعا انها تاخذ وقتا طويلا
لكن هذه الاجراءات القانونيه والحكوميه
التي يجب ان تتخذ رغم ان محكمه انتريو
اصدرت قرار ان هذه الجريمه هي جريمه
ارهابيه وانها ارسلت الى وزاره الخارجيه
دعوه قضائيه لارسالها مباشره الى النظام
الايراني وبالفعل وزاره الخارجيه ارسلت
هذه الدعوه القضائيه لكن النظام الايراني
لم يرد اصلا على هذه القضايا فقط لانه
نذكر المشاهدين عدد الاسر همم التي اخذت
قرارا بالتعويض من الاسر التي حتى الساعه
لم تاخذ حتى على مستوى القرار باي تعويض
من السلطات في ايران
ثلاثه منها اللي ظهرت اسمائهم لان البقيه
كانوا يخافون من التهديدات يخافون من
التهديدات النظام الايراني ثلاثه منها فقط
حصلت على قرار محكمه انتيريو بانهم
سيحصلون على تعويضات وانهم لهم الحق
بمصادره اي ممتلكات خاصه للنظام الايراني
في كندا وحولها لم ي- لم يحصلوا على اي
تعويض حاليا هي كانت بما يقارب 100 مليار
عفوا مليون وسبعه مليون دولار كندي يعني
لكن لم تحصل حتى الان هذه العائلات على
هذه الاموال لكنها حصلت على القرار بقيه
الاسر كانت تنتظر الحكومه الكنديه واين
اتصل باجراءاتها لكن اذا نحكي خلينا بما
انه تكلمنا عن التهديدات
العوائل الضحايا وصلتهم تهديدات كثيره
الطالب يعني هذه الثلاث سنوات يعني الى
جانب الحزن الذي عاشوه انا دخلت منازلهم
وشاهدت بعيني همم يعني تجد مثلا اب لحاله
يكون عايش مع الصور والشموع فقد ابنه
الوحيد في اب ثاني يعني خلى عليه البيت
اسرته بالكامل فهؤلاء اصبحوا لا يفكرون
بالتعويضات كانوا فقط يفكرون كيف سيحصلون
على الحقيقه كشف كشف الاسباب لماذا ترك
المجال الجوي مفتوحا هل لاستخدام
المسافرين
العربيه في كندا شكرا جزيلا لهذه المشكله
تويتر اجرت مزيدا من تخفيضات العماله
والتي شملت فريقي الثقه والامانه اللذين
يتعاملان مع موضوع الاشراف على المحتوى
العلمي بالاضافه الى الوحده المتعلقه
بخطاب الكلام
موجه تسريح جديده تنال من موظفي تويتر
[موسيقى]
عاملين في مكاتب الشركه في دبل و سنغافوره
من بين المفصولين رئيس سلامه الموقع في
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ وكبيره ومديريه سياسه
الايرادات في المنصه
التسريحاته على المحتوى والوحده المتعلقه
بخطاب الكراهيه بالمنصات
[موسيقى]
في عهد الى الماسك تويتر صرحت ثلاثه الاف
وسبعمائه موظف في نوفمبر الماضي
في العالميه الصين ترفع الحجر الصحي
المرتبط بكره
اهلا بكم جديد فتحت الاجهزه الامنيه
العراقيه جزئيه بوابات المنطقه الخضراء
بالعاصمه بغداد كما تمت ازاله 100 نقطه
تفتيش من شوارع العاصمه وذلك لاول مره منذ
اكتوبر من عام 2019
بهدف التقليل الازدحامات المروريه
داخل المنطقه الخضراء هذا النفق اللي ودي
يراجعك باتجاه التقاطع
الجمهوريه وخمس اربع مداخل لها
مخرج داخل المنطقه الخضراء وكذلك يتم رفع
اكثر من 107 سيطره خلال اليومين فتح منطقه
حي التشريع بجميع ابوابه وانفاقها امام
حركه المواطنين دخولها بدون بعض من الساعه
الخامسه صباحا الى الساعه 7:00 مساء
قبل تقاطعات مسدوده والاشوارك وبعض
الشوارع مسدوده فانفتح السير بس يعني
الحمد لله
هذا الشيء طبعا
موجوده وان شاء الله نتمنى الخير للعراق
والازدحام فقط يعني يعني اليوم انا اطلع
بسبعه زين يعني طريقه بالدوره الحي الجامع
يعني ياكل لفت ساعه نص ساعه هسه لا 15
دقيقه انا وصلت اليوم
اشار رئيس الوزراء السويديسون الى ان بلاد
هو ثقه من ان تركيا ستوافق على طلبها
للانضمام الى حل في شمال الاطلسي مؤكدا في
ذات الصدا لان السويد لا يمكنها تلبيه
جميع مطالب تركيا الى الحصول على دعم
عضويه النيك هذا وقعت السويد والفنلندا
وتركيا اتفاقيه ثلاثيه عام 20 22 تهدف الى
التغلب على اعتراضات تركيا على عضويه
البلدين
وتمهد الطريق لانضمام البلدين الى الحلم
يواجه الامير هاري ردود فعل واسعه في
اعصابي نشر مذكراته التي تضمنت اعترافات
وتشريبات تخص العائله المالكه البريطانيه
التي جاء من ابرزها اعتراف هاربي قتل 25
شخصا من حركه طالبان وتعرضه للاعتداء
للجسدي من اخيه الامير وليام اضافه الى
هجوم ضد العائله الملكيه البريطانيه
طيب بس كمان ببساطه
المتمردين اليس كذلك يبتعدون عن انفسهم
ويحاولون الابتعاد ايضا عن العائله
الملكيه
اعتقد ان الناس يشعرون بفضول حول النظام
الملكي وقصصه نريد ان نعرف ما حدث بالفعل
وما هي الاحداث التي حصلت
اعتقد ان هناك الكثير من الاشياء التي كان
من الممكن ان يتعمق فيها هاري لكنني اعتقد
انه كان يحترم عائلته وامتنع عن فعل ذلك
وبعد الجدل الذي صاحب نشره مذكرات الامير
هاري يبدا اليوم سلسله من المقابلات
التلفزيونيه معه والتي من المتوقع ان تحمل
المزيد من الانتقادات للعائله الملكيه
ويقولوا معلقون ان الكتابه ادخل العائله
المالكه في واحده من اكبر ازماتها
ثلاث مقابلات تلفزيونيه ستعرض اعتبارا من
اليوم وقد عرضت نقطه وفاه منها حيث قال
هاري انه يرغب في سرد القصه من وجهه نظرك
وتشير استطلاعات للراي لان كثيرا من
البريطانيين ضاق وذرعا بيملوا دراما
العائله المالكه برمتها وان الكشف عن مزيد
من المفاجات لن يغير ارائهم سواء
المتعاطفه مع هاري وزوجته ميغان او تلك
المنتقد لهما ولم يسلم هاري من الصحافه
البريطانيه التي سنتوجوما واسعا عليه
وتقول صحيفه الديليميرور انه لا احد بمناى
عن مهمه هاري الوحشيه لتدمير الاسره فيما
اتهمته صحيفه بالقاء عائلته تحت حافله من
اجل ملايين الدولارات
واعتبرت ان لا شيء يمكن ان يبرر المسار
الهدام والانتقمي الذي اختاره هاري
لا احد يعرف اين كانوا او ما كانوا
يفعلونه ليله وفاه والدتي بكيت مره واحده
اثناء مراسم الدفن ولا حاجه لخوض في مدى
غرابه الامر او الذنب الذي شعرت به انا
وويليام ايضا الجميع كانوا يعتقدون
ويشعرون بانهم يعرفون امي واقربوا شخصين
منها واكثر شخصين احبتهما لم يتمكنا من
التعبير عن اي مشاعرها في تلك اللحظه
الى موضوع اخر اعاده الصين رسميا فتحه
حدودها ورفع الحجر الصحي للقديمين من
الخارج
صحيه عالميه من ارتفاع حصيله اصابات كرونه
في وقت تعاني فيه مدن صينيه من نقص
للادويه وامتلاء المستشفيات بالمرضى
المسنين حيث تكافح البلاد اسوا تفشل
للفايروس على الاطلاق
الزاميه الحجر الصحي للمسافرين الوافدين
من الخارج بعد ثلاث سنوات من العزله عن
العالم في وقت تواجه فيه موجه وبائيه
جديده من الفايروس الحواجز التي كانت تفصل
الرحلات الدوليه القادمه عن تلك الداخليه
في مطار بكين اختفت فضلنا على الموظفين
ببزات واقيه بعد تطبيق القرار الصيني
وبالتالي تشهد البلاد ارتفاعا هائلا في
الحركه على مواقع حجز الرحلات مع تخطيط
الصينيين للسفر الى الخارج
انها خطوه ضروريه على ما اعتقد اصبحت
طبيعيا الان وبعد هذه العقبه سيكون كل شيء
سلسا
وفي هونغ كون ايضا تم تخفيف القيود
الصارمه للتنقلي من الصين واليها وهناك
عائلات تنتظر بفارغ الصبر ان تلتقي مجددا
بمناسبه راس السنه الصينيه
لقد مررت ثلاث سنوات والان الحدود مفتوحه
بلا عوائق
في عدد المسافرين من الصين دفعت اكثر من
12 بلدا كان اخرها هولندا والبرتغال الى
فرض اختبارات الزاميهم عند الوصول ممدده
بكين بهذه القيود التي فرضت على مواطنها
واعتبرتها غير مقبوله هذا وقالت منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان البيانات الرسميه
للاصابات في الصين لا تعكس نطاق الفعل
لتفش المرض كما تشير التوقعات باحتمال ان
يتفاقما انتشار الوباء في الصين خلال فتره
عطله راس السنه الصينيه نهايه الشهر
الحالي حيث يسافر الملايين من سكان المدن
الكبرى التي سجلت فيها اصابات كثيره الى
الارياف لزياره الاهل الذين غالبا ما يكون
المسنين وفي حاله ضعف
رشا خياطه العربيه
وسهلا بك ما الذي دفع السلطات الصينيه
لاتخاد مثل هكذا قرار رفع الحظر
في الوقت الذي تعاني فيه مدن صينيه عده من
تفشن كبير وواسع للفايروس هو الاوسع نطاقا
منذ بدء هذا الفايروس ما الذي ما عدا مما
بدا
احلامنا مرحبا بكم طبعا
يعني عدد فتح الحدود وهذا بسبب ان همم
حاليا الخصائص متحاورات او ميكروم اصبح
مختلفه همم
وانخفضت الكثير خطوره الفيروس
وكذلك همم
هناك المناعه يعني همم لقد تجاوز نسبه
الوقايه الحديثه 90% الكثير من همم السكان
عند همم يعني
اكتسب المناعه يعني
همم
وكذلك هذا تسهيل من اجل الانتعاش
الاقتصادي العالمي كذلك هل مبررات القرار
اذا هي مبررات تجاريه اقتصاديه بحته ام لا
الصين او بكين تعتبر ان الفيروس لم يعد
بالخطوره التي تهدد البلاد
الصين تعتقد ان هذه خطوره
الفيروس
مقارنه مع كان عليها في الماضي فهذا هو
سبب الرئيسي طيب كيف هي الاحوال سيد نادر
في المدن التي مازال يضربها الفايروس بعض
التقارير الاعلام يتحدث عن نقص كبير في
الادويه وعن عدم وجود اسره للمرضى في
المستشفيات الى اما هذا دقيق
حدا معظم المدن الصينيه مثل الكبرى مثل
الباكين يعني الان تجاوزت دوره الانتشار
ولعانه
الادويه يعني
موجوده وكل شيء موجوده والوضع مستمر
[موسيقى]
ولكن حاليا
73% همم
اثار
وتعاقب وعادت الى طبيعته يعني حياتها
الطبيعيه
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
شكرا شكرا لكم
كاليفورنيا يتسببت في انقطاع الكهرباء عن
مئه الالاف من المنازل والشركه فيما تستعد
المنطقه لموجه اخرى من الطقس السيء هذا قد
تم الابلاغ عن اكثر من 330 الف منزل وشركه
ما تزال بدون كهرباء فيما لقيا سته اشخاص
على الاقل حتفهم جرى الطقس السيء منذ عطله
راس السنه
الميلاديه
نشاط الخامسه من العربيه انتهت اطب
التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]